digamos que tengo una granja de ovejas
quizás un negocio de producción de lana
y en el primer año salí compre algunas
ovejas las puse en un terreno pague por
las ovejas un millón de dólares y pagué
por el terreno 1.2 millones de dólares
por lo que en activos tengo 2.2 millones
de dólares hasta aquí todo está claro
ahora veamos el segundo año y veamos
cómo vamos a contabilizar las ovejas y
el terreno una manera es decir bueno
las ovejas ahí están el terreno también
ahí sigue pague a un millón de dólares
por las ovejas y como aún siguen ahí
pues siguen valiendo un millón de
dólares y pague 1.2 millones por el
terreno y el terreno sigue estando allá
así que conservo este activo de 1.2
millones de dólares en este ejemplo
contabiliza a mis ovejas y a mi terreno
con base en su costo histórico vamos a
escribirlo
esto está con base en su costo histórico
costo histórico y esa es una manera
legítima de contabilizar lo
especialmente si no sabemos el valor de
las ovejas y del terreno en la
actualidad vale lo que yo pague por
ellos pero digamos que hay un mercado
activo con las ovejas y puede llegar un
valuador de ovejas a nuestra granja para
decirnos lo que valen nuestras ovejas el
valor viene de nuestra granja revisa
nuestras ovejas y nos dice oye se ven
muy bien pero fíjate que ha habido una
epidemia en otros lugares del país y hay
escasez por lo que sus ovejas valen
mucho más de lo que pagaste por ellas y
nos dice que él cree que nuestras ovejas
valen 2 millones de dólares y nosotros
decimos guau el valor en el mercado de
mis ovejas es 2 millones así que en
lugar de poner un millón acá vamos a
poner 2 millones por mis ovejas y
digamos que también el valor del terreno
ha aumentado se han construido
carreteras cercanas y a lo mejor alguien
quiere construir un conjunto
habitacional cercano por lo que el valor
del terreno ahora es también de 2
millones de dólares
y que estos dos que por cierto son
millones esto de aquí lo podemos ver
como el valor en el mercado o el valor
justo en el mercado el valor justo de
nuestros activos cualquiera de estas dos
formas son formas legítimas de
contabilizar nuestros activos pero es
bueno conocer la diferencia entre ellas
es la contabilidad de costos histórico y
esa es la contabilidad del valor justo
en general
esta última contabilidad necesita de una
persona que reporte el valor en el
mercado actual de nuestros activos tan
frecuentemente como sea posible eso es
muy fácil de hacer si tenemos una
persona que nos está informando de estos
valores en el mercado actual y así
tendremos un muy buen estimado de lo que
valen estos activos si no tenemos acceso
a este tipo de personas o es algo poco
eficiente entonces mejor entonces será
mejor que usemos el costo histórico como
forma de contabilizar esa es toda la
diferencia entre ellas el costo
histórico significa cuánto pagamos por
nuestros activos el precio justo es el
precio actual en el mercado de estos
activos